ragazzi ciao a tutti ho il piacere di
avere cui michele eccolo che è stato un
pochino una sorpresa di oggi sarà
indicata a casa un aggiornamento
pazzesco sono stati che tu non sai mai
un grande aggiornamento ragazzi su
mozart come uno dei miei cantanti
preferiti con il mio youtuber preferito
che meraviglia che bel regalo mi avete
fatto grazie
so che ti piace la mia voce anche il
rimanente social e ti riassumo mozart è
un ragazzo col quale mi ero sentito
ormai l'anti tanti mesi fa per il kun è
vero
ora mi chiederai se ti sorprende che il
culo perché non sono ancora arrivato al
momento di mozart importante questo
ragazzo qualità ma sentirci però
scompariva la sera scopro che è
fidanzatissimo quello classico quando ho
iniziato a vederci lui mi guardava e mi
diceva sai io ovviamente non sapevi
fosse fidanzato lo sapevo che fosse che
danno fare però bisogna pure detto non è
un problema mio
perché si sa il calcio è come una
bussola in volte presente a 30 sempre a
nord cioè non so come dire quindi non è
una cosa che puoi comandare a volte
scusate ragazzi che sono sincero e
quindi iniziamo a vederci e lui parte
con degli scorsi tipo senti ma anche tu
senti quello che sento io un po
prematuro cioè nel senso comunque c'è
questa roba che mi blocca tanto non è
che con dato troppo a fondo il
mangiatutto vip a no perché ti spiego io
in realtà sto cercando una persona persa
nel tempo tu credi nella rincarnazione
io pur di fare colpo detto certo
figurativo no perché io cerco mozart lui
era stato insieme a mozart si era amato
tantissimo e quindi cercava questi occhi
verdi riavvicinandosi ai miei occhi mi
disse che sono effettivamente un po
verdi partito capire il livello di giuro
mozart e poi sono scappato io dalla
situazione ma lo zar ci sono stati gli
sviluppi l'ultimo sviluppo e che mi ha
scritto lui sentiva detto di mozart
ti dico solo io mi sono messo a cercare
la data di morte di mozart per capire se
la costellazione fosse simile a quella
mia per capire se potessi essere ma
comunque
allora posso dire che io con quel
pianoforte faccio nei miracoli e quindi
forse nelle vene avere avevo qualcosa
avevo qualcosa lui era fissato con me
però il fatto che fosse fidanzato poi al
fatto che fosse fidanzato si è aggiunto
anche il fatto che miri a vedere una
foto di questa fatidica manco vale la
storia oppure matto mi scrive ai lavori
anche oggi ragazzi preparatevi
credo che sia tempo perso ad avere
un'amicizia anche virtuale con te quindi
che avesse un addio definitivo perotti
sogni sono sempre stato bene con te e
ora di cercare altrove grazie di tutto
ora che sono libero si è lasciato tu sei
impegnato nel tuo lavoro ti voglio bene
v anche se non ci rivedremo più pensa
fosse una frecciatina cioè se io le
agorà che sono libero pensate cioè se ti
sta lasciando ora che sono libero mi
sono liberato di e la preintesa così
spero che noi siamo un lato perché c'era
braccio il compagno vabbè io gli ho
risposto di poco dice tu sei libera che
possa finalmente vivere i tuoi desideri
nella tua verità e quindi se i ragazzi
un bacio sul cuore a tutti quanti e in
bocca al lupo con le vostre verità
ragazzi questo sempre comunque gus è un
grande in un momento difficile la mia
vita dopo essere stato lasciato ad
essermi beccato pure le corna dopo nove
anni di storia i tuoi video mi hanno
rasserenato e fatto stare meglio grazie
al suo discorso sulle storie lunghe che
poi finiscono improvvisamente ea un
certo punto ci sono le cornee c'è tutta
questa roba qui io ho una mia teoria
molto forte sul fatto che una storia
duri così tanto e poi finisca la mia
teoria che in parte quella storia dopo
nove anni sono almeno quattro anni che
si trascina almeno di latenza è esatto e
un tempo di latenza che sono che viene
dopo una fortissima passione iniziale
che magari ti può portare anche a tre
anni d'amore quattro anni di
meraviglioso amore ma di solito quella
che chi si lascia la nostra lunga dice
sempre siamo stati insieme quattro anni
ma realtà erano due di amore vero che
proprio volevamo stare insieme era molto
meno rispetto a quanto siamo stati
insieme io la storia di due anni che
alteri di tre mesi ma così vero che io
io la storia più
non è stata di 4 anni però in realtà
dicevo sempre un anno forse poco meno
che veramente volevo stare questa
perfezione roja un certo molto soli tre
anni e di noi a non provare a
risistemare ricucire è chiaramente no
quello invece il tuo discorso su tutto
quello che è l'ambito rendimenti al
compagnia bella
io non ho mai tradito lo so di esser
stato tradito però io sono molto pignolo
sulla chiarezza nelle relazioni cioè
proprio sono una persona di pignola del
mondo crede di essere franco se stai
cercando compagnia stai cercando una
storia se le cose non vanno altri
costruite a gradi proprio è capitato
molte volte di dire mi trovo molto bene
con te ma quello che stiamo facendo
adesso e tenerci compagnia perché stai
bene zia magari diventa le cose cosa
esclusiva però non è una storia non so
se è chiaro che tipo quello che
sperimento il più ovvio tra l'equipe tre
persone usano le parole al chilo e
quindi volano magari delle parole forti
che per me hanno un peso e quindi magari
linee ad alta metto a facendo un disegno
può in realtà nei fatti è tutto diverso
in tempo io cercavo di leggere tra le
righe ricercavo quindi di attribuire
proiettare ridere anche il minimo
embrione di un qualcosa che potesse
funzionare volte posto diventa solo a
posto io credo che di base la maggior
parte degli atti che vengono fatti
nostri confronti e spesso magari ci
chiediamo perché non funziona perché non
m'ha chiamato perché non ma cagato
perché mi ha risposto così perché mi ha
risposto con linee molto più dura
rispetto a quella che vogliamo credere
se come noi aver insegnato una forma di
dicotomia è un po tossica e nociva cioè
o funziona o non funziona e non ci viene
mai insegnato che esistono invece un
sacco di ibridi che vanno avanti ai
quali non sono interessato e ci hai
davanti se una versione era bianco per
me ad oggi si è veramente nel tempo e
diventare quali prima persona nel solo
per impegnarti se frequento e quindi se
ho un tipo di atteggiamento all'interno
di una relazione che è costruttivo è
perché ho voglia di impegnarmi e per me
è difficile dirlo così c'è un percorso
molto più lento io non ho mai avuto il
colpo di fulmine
no io sì ma è per quello che sono ci
credo per niente
quella cosa credo che l'alchimia esista
cioè poco un fattore cunico ddd
epidermico nove canali elettriche
proprio c'è una combinazione giusta con
l'altra persona e questo si va ad aprire
non lo so dopo un tot di merito con tot
di anni e parlata la inizia proprio
l'arte del costruire insieme una cosa
che possa durare in un rapporto io dico
diciamo i tre semini tre embrioni chiama
lei come ti pare che per me sono
fondamentali sesso se non mi funziona
l'erotismo io non son minimamente cosa
cioè se un amico meraviglioso cs
un'intesa mentale se non mi fa ridere se
non riesco a parlare a sé un pazzesco
trombamico è che manca la terza la terza
è ed è quella più difficile per me
trovare perché io ho avuto a che fare
con persone con le quali ho letto
wow anche con le chiacchiere wow ma non
c'era quella frazione quella roba che se
mi sfiori mentre sta mangiando io già mi
imbarazzo attento a tutto quello che
dico e tutte questi tre fattori e non
vuol dire che sono automaticamente nel
mio colpo di fulmine arrivati è
ovviamente il fatto che mi rendo conto
di stare tanto è una persona che ha le
potenzialità per potermi piacere per
sempre sai che quella casa mi è successa
sempre tanto dopo nel tempo io mi sono
innamorato solo una volta ma me ne sono
accorto veramente alto dopo una domanda
allora sai cos'è primi sessualità
i primi sessuali sono per esempio quelle
persone che per poter avere un tipo di
interesse sessuale confronti una persona
devono avere prima una forma di
connessione emotiva
forse quello primi due fattori decisone
impensabile anche solo per tenersi
compagnia pesa solo per dire passiamo
che non siamo il tempio di venere
ci teniamo compagnia nella ricerca di
des atto che è una cosa che pure io
provo che la questione fatto anche con
grande pulizia e cioè poi aggredire
guarda non è scattata quella cosa però
gentilmente diciamo passiamo del tempo
insieme ci teniamo conto di cinque pasti
scholes lentissima il soccorso sono
molto termine ma sai perché perché c'è
una cosa che mi sono accorto che in
realtà lo so faccio l'esempio c'è una
mia amica federica
una relazione eterosessuale ha una
struttura emotiva il rapporto con
l'altra persona molto chiara mi sono
accorto poi magari una generalizzazione
sbagliata che nel mondo omosessuale è
molto più complicato c'è un tipo di
leggerezza su alcuni aspetti molto forte
un tipo di le cose che magari su una
relazione eterosessuali sono più leggere
diventano più pesanti nell'altra cosa
cambiano i valori proprio un sistema
valoriale diverso ed è molto più
complessa perché c'è anche un tipo di
rapporto che è molto più diretto è
capito dovere sensore con ragazze che
storia con ragazzi le storie con i
ragazzi sono molto più franchi e quindi
metti il linguaggio della parola davanti
al linguaggio del corpo
io credo che una relazione dello
sessuale per molto più storia da
ricavare esatto si è più abituati a
conoscerne il funzionamento già forti e
non sono eterosessuale hanno meno
storico ci sono meno impronte da
ripercorrere e come se fosse un terreno
più nuovo e quindi tante cose si trovano
per la prima volta che chiaramente tanti
riferimenti di storie eterosessuali
bechi cina cc cresci la nostra
generazione conoscevamo sessualità
diversa da come quando siamo nati
facoltà con le relazioni omosessuali c'è
molta meno strata già percorso è molto
meno terra battuta e quindi sono molti
più sentieri da esplorare perché poi in
quella terra venga abbattuta l'unica
cosa secondo me che il mondo gay uomo
uomo ed è quella forse era sembrata più
paura perché non mi da parte di bernanke
ha una capacità di essere estremamente
diretto dal punto proprio di vista
fisico qualsiasi gay potrebbe fare così
e [ __ ] ma quella roba lì non è per
me relazione semplicemente saini neve è
stata una cosa di grande ispirazione
quando io ho iniziato a scoprire la mia
sessualità quindi anche a ad avere
storia con ragazze e così via
chiaramente il rapporto con la
corporalità così forte così importante
all'inizio mi ha un po di stabilita
perche non era abituato però per me di
grande ispirazione perché mi ha dato
modo due punti che dicevi all'inizio la
parte intellettuale della parte fisica
di accettare che hanno lo stesso livello
hanno lo stesso valore prima per me
erano sbilanciati c'è il coraggio di
comunicare con il corpo l'esattezza di
quello che ha in testa essere venuto
per me di grande ispirazione molte volte
capita poi quando fai sti discorsi
sembra sempre di fare l'apologia della
botta e via non è però avere proprio una
chiarezza nel dire io con il corpo
adesso voglio dirti questa cosa che con
le parole non riesco e questa cosa
diventa magari un uomo di essere diretto
molto forte questa una sua sempre
raccontata come cosa che un uomo essendo
come te tu sei più libero di poter anche
ferire tra virgolette perché io a volte
ho problemi a dire non è scattata non mi
piace cioè mi sento subito in
paticamente in colpa con l'altra persona
come se la stessa e rifiutando come se
fossi io come la prendere io e quindi ci
sto malissimo e un tempo io pensavo che
una donna mi avrebbe ucciso e quindi
inizialmente mi sono raccontato che una
cosa con gli ultimi nieri al costo non
[ __ ] anche quegli uomini cioè non
riesce quando come detto che per te è
importante la chiarezza io ti dico che
nelle mie relazioni se c'è una cosa che
mi viene sempre stato detto è tu devi
essere più chiaro per non riesco è una
testata se tu non lo sai non ri e non è
che non riesco a dirti tutto guardi una
rampa che dico sempre che poi mi capita
ad altre volte di incaponirmi tanto su
questa cosa se non c'è chiarezza per me
è proprio il primo motivo di rottura è
come se uno avesse un proprio alfabeto
braille l'alfabeto emotivo inglese io
all'alfabeto emotivo francese ok se ti
dico una parola tu non la capisci e
andiamo avanti quel discorso ai delle
lacune e quindi magari che ho detto
delle cose belle delle cose brutte delle
cose inutili solo che non ne sai
classificare quando dico una parola che
non capisce quando il miart babette sta
parlando una cosa che tu non riesci a
ritradurre e se devi dire fermo cosa
volevi dire con quella parola con quel
gesto la possibilità di avere un
vocabolario e dire ok questa tua azione
corrisponde a prato un esempio per me
dormire insieme non ha questo peso
enorme che tante persone danno ma so che
quell'azione espone il fianco a mille
interpretazioni e quindi dico guarda per
me non c'è problema a fare questa cosa
ma nel mio alfabeto dormire insieme
corrisponde a questo te nel tuo dormire
insieme
questo è importante perché qui tu fai
una chiacchiera conoscitiva c'è un
colloquio rimanere in corsa ma capisci
lo supera
cioè si parla del
non è che non lo so stai un bar parli
del tuo lavoro e per un certo punto
scatta il limone ma è così il piano e 1
c gira un po in tutti annusi ma come una
fase di annusata io la riesce a trovare
il modo per no io invece trovo che
sottotesto a volte parli da sé ma magari
sono un parla da sé
se avete lo stesso vocabolo che questa
cosa non la puoi dare per scontata
[Musica]